Humans used hunting or gathering to survive. But humans are cleverly lazy
We have made tools to facilitate our work. From the sticks to the plows to the tractors and the shift from the position
Everyone needs to produce food to the current agriculture without almost anyone needing to produce
Food and yet we have abundance
And of course this is not only in agriculture, but everything we have spent thousands of years
We make tools to reduce physical effort of all kinds. These muscles are mechanical
Stronger, more dependable, and less tired than human muscles can be
This is good. Replacing human effort with mechanical muscles saves human time for specialization.
This leaves everyone better off, even those who are still physically active. So grow
The economy is improving and living standards are improving
Some people specialize in being programmers and engineers. Their job is to build minds
Mechanical. As mechanical muscles reduced the demand for human effort, just like mechanical brains
Reduce demand on human minds
This is an economic revolution. You may think we've gone through this situation before but we have not
This is a different situation
# Human effort #
When you think of automation, you often think about it: massive, specially crafted robots
Expensive but very stupid, ignorant of the world and about her work. It was a scary type
Of automation but did not seize the world for it
Cost-effective in a few cases
But the old kind of automation, this is the modern type
I offer you Baxter
In contrast to these things that need skilled operators and technicians and millions
Of dollars. Baxter can see and can learn what you want to do by watching and doing
It costs less than the average annual wage of a human worker. Unlike his brothers
Adults do not have pre-programmed for one job, can do any work under
Good. Baxter can be thought of as a general-purpose robot
Being for the general purpose is important.
Think of computers, also began to be specially manufactured and very expensive, but when they appeared
The relatively cheap calculus became necessary for everything quickly
A general purpose computer can easily calculate the change or identify seats on the plane
Play a game or do anything just by changing its programs. This is a strong demand for computers
Of all types is what makes it the strongest and cheapest every year
Baxter today is like a computer in the eighties. It is not the summit, but the beginning
Despite Baxter's slow hourly cost of electricity consumption of pennies while his human rivals
They charge the minimum wage. Ten speed is cost effective when it costs
One hundred times less. And while Baxter is not smart some things
Which we will talk about is clever enough to take on a lot of skill-less jobs
We have already seen less intelligent robots from Baxter replacing jobs. In modern stores
What was a job occupied by 30 people is occupied by one person watching 30 robotic treasurer
Or a hundred thousand barista workers in the world will bring robot Barista to them
Of course, the barista you know makes the moka double whatever you like and you will never trust anyone
Another, but millions of people do not care and just want a good cup of coffee. By the way
This robot is actually a huge network you remember
And how you like your coffee wherever you are. Very comfortable order
We think of technological progress as modern, exciting and expensive, but real change is happening
When the things of the last decade become cheaper and faster. This is what happens now to robots
And the ability of their mechanical minds to make decisions wins in competition with
Humans to function in a way can not muscle. Pure human competition with it
# Horsepower #
Imagine a pair of horses in the early 20th century talking about technology. One of them worries that
These modern mechanical muscles will make horses unnecessary
The other reminds us that every technological development so far extends their lives "I remember all that work
On the farm? Remember the enemy from the beach to the beach to deliver mail? Do you remember going to battle?
They are all ugly. These jobs in the city are very convenient "and with the presence of all these people in the city has become
There are more jobs for horses than before
Even if this thing is called a car may say there will be new jobs for horses
We can not imagine it
But you, my dear viewers of the years after 2000 know what happened, there are still many working horses
But not as before. Census of horses reached its peak in 1915 and since then
Continue to decrease
There is no rule in the economy that states that the best technology offers newer and better jobs
For horses. This sentence sounds so dumb, but if we replace the word horses with humans
Suddenly people think it is a correct sentence
Just as mechanical muscles have replaced the place of horses in the economy will do mechanical minds
The same for humans. Not immediately and not everywhere but in very large numbers and soon enough
So much so that it will become a big problem if we do not prepare. And we are not ready
Like a second horse, you may consider putting technology up now and you think it is not possible
To replace your job but technology is getting better and cheaper and faster than you can not
Living organisms compete with it
Just as the car was the beginning of the end for the horses now the car was strewn
This is what will come from things
#the cars#
The cars that drive themselves are not the future but are now working. These cars moved
Two hundred thousand miles on the coast of California during the cities
And all this without driver intervention
The question is not "Will they replace cars?" But no matter how fast they change, they do not need to be excellent
They only need to be better than us. Incidentally kills 40,000 human error each
General in the United States only. Because the cars that drive themselves do not blink
Do not send phone messages as they drive, do not sleep or do dumb things easy to see them become more efficient than
From humans it is already so
But naming cars that drive themselves as cars is like naming the initial cars horses
Mechanical. Horse cars outperform everything in such a way that the use of the word horses limits
Of your thinking about what you can do. To call cars that lead themselves to what they are
:on him
Auto: "The solution to the problem of connecting things from point A to point B is" traditional cars happen to be suitable for size
Humans for human transport But small autos can operate in warehouses and the giant Otto can
To work in open mines. Who knows how much function depends on the transfer of things but sector
Transportation in the United States employs about three million individuals and an inductive estimate of at least 70 million
Function in the world
These jobs will disappear
The usual view is that unions will prevent them, but history is full of workers
They fought the technology that later replaced them and the workers lost each time. The economy wins
There are always great incentives in various industries to adopt the auto
For many transport companies, humans have about a third of their total costs. This cost
Are only wages. Sleeping in long trucks costs time and money
Costs cost money, negligence costs money and if you think that insurance companies will oppose
This change, you are wrong, for them the excellent driver is the one who pays their small premium and does not cause
.accidents
Autos are coming and is the first place where most people will see
Robots change society. But this change occurs in many economic places
But it is not visible
As with the Otto, it will happen with everything
# What will come from things #
##Office Posts ##
It is easy to look at the Otto and Baxter and think that as long as the technology has gotten rid of
One of the few jobs is to rely on the skill that people do not want to do. They will increase specialization and work
More jobs depending on higher education, as they have always done
Even if we ignore the disaster of imposing higher education on another hundred million people
Office work is not safe if your job is to sit in front of a screen
Writing and clicking (just as it is supposed to do now) robots will come
You too, my dear
The software robots are more concrete, faster and much cheaper than physical robots
And because office functions (from a corporate perspective) are more expensive and more
The motivation to automate their work is even greater
This is the function of automation engineers. These are skilled programmers and their job
The whole thing is to replace your job with a software robot
You might think that the smartest translation engineer in the world can not make a robot to do
(And you may be right) but the level of progress in programming is not smart programmers
They program robots, but smart programmers program robots to teach themselves how to
Things that the programmer can not know
How this happens outside of this video but the bottom line is that
There are limited ways to teach robots how things work. But if a robot is offered a quantity of things that are made correctly
He can find out how to do the job
Even with a goal only and no example of how to reach this goal robots can learn. If we take
The bourse (which in many ways is no longer a function for humans) is often robots that have taught themselves
To trade shares with other robots taught themselves
For the second time: these are not robots carrying out orders according to what a human router wants
They are robots that decide what to buy and what to sell on their own
As a result, the New York Stock Exchange is no longer full of stock traders
They do their daily work it's a great TV studio
So robots learned the market and also learned to write. If you've just grabbed a newspaper
I often read a news story written by a robot
Learn robots to write anything: sports articles, test reports, procedure specifications, and even quarter reports
The year you write in your work
Paperwork, decision-making and writing Many human work is in this box
The demand for human mental work in these fields is about to decline, but of course the professions
You're safe from robots, are not you?
# Professions #
When you think about the legal profession it is easy to imagine trials. But the majority of the lawyer's work
"Drafting legal documents and anticipating the possible outcome and impact of judicial proceedings and so-called" discovery
And in which the office of the lawyer gives boxes of papers and on it
To find a repetitive pattern or find a transformation not in a locality in all the papers
This can become a robot function. Special discovery is not a human function in many law firms already
Not because there are no papers to investigate, there is more to it than ever, but because
Smart search robots scan millions of emails, notes, and accounts within hours
And not weeks, to defeat their human competitors not only by cost and time but by the most important
.Precision. Robots do not feel sleepy while reading millions of messages
But these are just simple things: I have a robot company called Watson. Maybe I saw him on television
Jeopardy is crushing his human rivals in a program but this was a side-project of entertainment for him
Watson's daily mission is to be the best doctor in the world to understand what people are saying in their words
And gives them accurate diagnoses. And already does so in the center
Where he advises on Slone-Kettering lung cancer treatments
Just as with Otto they do not need to be excellent, just need to make mistakes less than humans
As with a doctor robot
Human physicians are by no means excellent, as the frequency and severity of cases of diagnosis are poor
Terrifying, and severely incapacitated human physicians in dealing with the complex medical record
Of the patient. Understand the effect of each drug and its interaction with each drug
The last thing is beyond the scope of human knowledge
Especially when there are research robots whose full function is to test thousands of properties
At the same time
Physicians can improve through their expertise. Doctors can learn from doctors
The experiences of each robot and other doctor read the latest medical research and follow up everything that happens
To all their patients around the world and to find connections from
It is impossible to deduce in another way
Not all doctors will disappear, but when the comparison between robots, doctors and human beings,
Keep in mind that you can access them through your phone
So the professionals, the office workers and the low-skilled workers are worried
.from him
But perhaps you are not worried because you are a unique creator but
Let me tell you, you are not so unique
# Creative work #
Creativity may seem magical, but it is not. The mind is a complex machine, perhaps
The most complicated machines in the whole universe, but that did not stop us from trying
His mimics
There is a theory that just as mechanical muscles allowed us to move to mental work
Mechanical minds will allow us to move on to creative work. But even if we assume
That the human mind is magically creative (though not), but for the purpose of discussion we will assume that
Creativity is not what most jobs depend on. Represents the number of writers and poets
Directors, actors and artists who rely on these jobs a small percentage
Very strong workforce. And because these functions depend
On the grassroots, will always represent a small proportion of the population
There is nothing to claim economics of poems and paintings
And by the way, this musician with the background you hear now is a robot
She can write Emily Howell's number of endless pieces
All day and free. People can not distinguish between them and human authors when they are done
Test them
The talk of artificial creativity turns to strange talk quickly ... what is the meaning of this term originally
And yet it is a growing field
People thought that playing chess was a unique creative skill for humans and could not
To do it correctly until they beat our best. This will be the case for every human talent
#Conclusion#
Well, this may be too much to absorb and may want to reject. It is
Easy to mop up endless and foolish expectations for the future will not be. Therefore
It is necessary to stress again: this is not the creation of science fiction, these robots
here right now. There is an awful amount of automation in the laboratories and warehouses
around the world
We have been through economic revolutions before. But the robots' revolution is different
Horses are not idle now because they have become lazy as sex, they are not suitable for work
There is little work the horse can do to pay for his home and food
Many smart and capable people will find themselves in the horse's shop: they do not work
Without committing a sin
And if you still think that modern jobs will save us, you have to look at a final point
In 1776, the United States Statistics Office collected data on a small number of jobs. Now there are hundreds
But the modern ones do not represent a large proportion of the workforce
This list of jobs is ranked in descending order according to the number of people who perform it, and it is a list that comes up
The mind and the transport sector in the first place and examining the rest of the list, we find that all these works existed
In one form or another a hundred years ago and nearly all are easy targets for automation. Just
When we reach number 33 in this list we finally find something new
Do not think that every barista and office employee should lose his job before a problem arises
Where the unemployment rate during the Great Depression was 25%
While the previous list represents 45% of the workforce. What we talked about today only, what works efficiently
He can pay unemployment above this figure in the near future and because even in
In our technological world, modern jobs do not represent a small percentage of the economy
This is a big problem
This video is not about the ugliness of automation, but its inevitability
It is a way to create abundance with little effort. We must start planning from now on what we do
When a large proportion of the population becomes unfit for work, without committing a sin
, What we will do in a future where for most jobs people will not progress